>>> TOILET JOKE --
TOILET-GATE -- I TOTALLY AM HE
ISSED TH UP -- TOILET-GATE MAY
SOUND LIKE A JOKE.
>> TOILET JOKE IS COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT.
>> THIS IS NOT A JOKE, BUT THE
ALLEGATIONS THEY ARE REALLY NO
LAUGHING MATTER HERE.
IN HER NEW BOOK MAGGIE HABERMAN
OF THE "NEW YORK TIMES" CONFIRMS
A HABIT OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT
THAT WASN'T JUST UNHEALTHY FOR
THE WHITE HOUSE PLUMBING, IT WAS
BAD FOR THE PRESIDENCY AS WELL.
AND SHE'S GOT THE PHOTOS TO
PROVE IT.
THEY'RE KIND OF GROSS BUT ALSO
VERY IMPORTANT.
TELL US WHAT WE ARE LOOKING AT
HERE.
>> BRIANNA, THANKS FOR HAVING
ME.
GROSS AND IMPORTANT I THINK ARE
THE TWO IMPORTANT WORDS HERE.
WHAT YOU ARE LOOKING AT IS TWO
PHOTOS, ONE FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
WHICH IS THE ONE THAT LOOKS LIKE
IT HAS CARPET ON THE BOTTOM, THE
OTHER FROM AN OVERSEAS TRIP THAT
A TRUMP WHITE HOUSE SOURCE
PROVIDED ME RECENTLY AFTER SOME
OF THE REVELATIONS DURING THE
JANUARY 6th HEARING.
THIS PERSON, LIKE A NUMBER OF
STAFFERS I SPOKE WITH, WHILE
SOME OF THE TESTIMONY THAT HAS
BEEN HEARD HAS BEEN DISPUTED,
GENERALLY FOUND THE OVERALL
PICTURE OF TRUMP TO BE PRETTY
FAMILIAR WITH WHAT THEY HAD
EXPERIENCED AND THEY WANTED TO
SHARE THEM.
AGAIN, AS YOU SAY, PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO MAKE JOKES ABOUT
TOILETS AND SO FORTH, IT WOULD
STILL BE A STORY IF IT WAS A
FIREPLACE.
THE POINT IS ABOUT THE
DESTRUCTION OF RECORDS WHICH ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE PRESERVED UNDER
THE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT
WHICH IS A WATERGATE-ERA
CREATION.
>> MAGGIE, REMIND US OF THAT
PART OF THE STORY BECAUSE THESE
PICTURES CONFIRM SOMETHING THAT
YOU BROKE BEFORE IN THIS EARLY
RELEASE OF YOUR BOOK "CONFIDENCE
MAN" OUT THIS FALL, WE'RE
EXCITED TO SEE THE WHOLE BOOK
BASED ON THE PICTURES AND
REPORTING COMING OUT, BUT YOU
REPORTED THAT WHITE HOUSE
INSIDERS WERE TELLING US ABOUT
THE DESTRUCTION OF KEY WHITE
HOUSE DOCUMENTS.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
AND, JOHN, LOOK, WE KNEW THAT
TRUMP HAD A HABIT OF RIPPING UP
PAPER AND THAT PEOPLE HAD TO
TAPE IT BACK TOGETHER, MY
COLLEAGUE REPORTED THAT STORY, I
THINK ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
STORIES WRITTEN DURING THE TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE.
THIS MEANT THAT THEY COULDN'T BE
PRESERVED.
WHAT WAS HAPPENING WAS WHITE
HOUSE RESIDENT STAFF WERE
FINDING PIPES WERE CLOGGED WITH
PAPER THAT THEY BELIEVED HE HAD
FLUSHED DOWN.
I HAVE HAD ADDITIONAL REPORTING
AFTERWARDS FROM PEOPLE
CONFIRMING THAT TRUMP HAD INDEED
DONE THIS AND THAT IT HAPPENED
ON AT LEAST TWO FOREIGN TRIPS
AND IN THE WHITE HOUSE
THROUGHOUT HIS PRESIDENCY.
AGAIN, IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE
WHO KNOWS WHAT THIS PAPER WAS,
ONLY HE WOULD KNOW AND
PRESUMABLY WHOEVER WAS DEALING
WITH HIM, BUT THE IMPORTANT
POINT IS ABOUT THE RECORDS.
>> I URGE PEOPLE TO ZOOM IN.
YOU CAN SEE IT'S A SHARPIE, IT'S
HIS HANDWRITING.
HOW IS HIS CAMP RESPONDING TO
THIS, MAGGIE?
>> THESE WERE PUBLISHED BY
AXIOS, BY MIKE ALLEN FIRST AND I
BELIEVE THE SPOKESPERSON FOR THE
FORMER PRESIDENT GAVE A
STATEMENT SUGGESTING THAT, YOU
KNOW, IT REQUIRES DESPERATION TO
RUN SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
THAT'S FINE.
I MEAN, THIS WOULD BE A STORY
REGARDLESS OF WHO THE PRESIDENT
WAS.
>> AND, MAGGIE, TO BE CLEAR,
WHEN YOU PUT OUT THIS REPORTING
BEFORE THEY ATTACKED THE
REPORTING, BUT THIS PROVES WHAT
YOU WROTE TO BEGIN WITH, RIGHT?
>> RIGHT.
THEY ATTACKED THE REPORTING,
ATTACKED ME PERSONALLY, YOU
KNOW, THIS IS -- THIS WAS A
TRUMP WHITE HOUSE SOURCE, YOU
KNOW, IDENTIFYING PICTURES THAT
ACCORDING TO THE SOURCE SHOWED
THAT WHAT I REPORTED WAS
ACCURATE.
MAGGIE -- AXIOS PUBLISHED MAGGIE
HABERMAN'S REPORTING.
SHE REPORTED THEY FOUND
DOCUMENTS IN TRUMP'S TOILET.
LOOKS LIKE THEY WERE FLUSHED
DOWN, INTENTIONALLY DISPOSED OF.
AXIOS SHOWING THESE PHOTOS.
ONE IN THE WHITE HOUSE, ANOTHER
ONE IS DURING SOME KIND OF A
TRIP.
I KNOW PEOPLE ARE GOING TO MAKE
ALL KINDS OF TOILET JOKES HERE.
THE BOTTOM LINE, THESE ARE
DOCUMENTS THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE PRESERVED BEING DESTROYED
HERE, DANA.
>> IT'S NOT LEGAL.
I MEAN, THERE IS A LAW THAT IS
IN PLACE SINCE THE ERA
POST-NIXON THAT YOU HAVE TO
PRESERVE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS.
THAT IS THE PEOPLE WHO WORK IN
THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE MAN WHO
WAS ELECTED TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND THAT IS THE RULE.
WHICH IS WHY YOU HAVE SEEN
REPORTING FROM MAGGIE AND
OTHERS, THE THEN PRESIDENT HAD A
HABIT OF RIPPING THINGS UP AND
THROWING THEM IN THE TRASH.
HIS AIDES WOULD COME QUICKLY
ALONG AND TAKE THEM OUT OF THE
TRASH AND TAPE THEM BACK
TOGETHER, BECAUSE THAT IS THE
LAW OF THE LAND.
THIS LOOKS NEFARIOUS.
WE DON'T KNOW THE SPECIFICS.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE'RE GOING TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF WHAT
EXACTLY WAS IN THERE BECAUSE
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE THE
FORMER PRESIDENT COP TO IT.
THERE'S NO INDICATION THAT IS
SOMETHING HE WOULD DO.
I WAS ZOOMING IN ON MY PHONE ON
MY PICTURES.
I'M SURE YOU GUYS WERE ALSO.
>> YEAH.
>> IT'S A SHARPIE AND IT LOOKS
LIKE DONALD TRUMP'S HANDWRITING.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT.
CAN WE PROVE IT?
ARE WE HANDWRITING EXPERTS?
NO.
BUT IT'S JUST NOT LEGAL, FULL
STOP.